mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
if x to the power of 5 is equal to 1
solve for all values of the sum of the
following four fractions
the first fraction is x divided by 1
plus x squared the second fraction is x
squared divided by 1 plus x to the power
of 4
the third fraction is x cubed divided by
1 plus x and the last fraction is x to
the power 4 divided by 1 plus x cubed
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we can get started by guessing a
solution to this equation
if x to the power of five is equal to
one
then one value that satisfies this
equation is x is equal to one
we can substitute this value and then we
can simplify each fraction
all four fractions become the same value
of one over two
the sum of these fractions will then be
equal to two
this is if x is equal to one
but what if x is not equal to one
we will show you we'll get exactly the
same result that the sum of the
fractions is equal to two
to see why we'll get started with x to
the power of five is equal to one
we'll multiply both sides of this
equation by x to get x to the power of
six is equal to x we'll take this
equation and then multiply both sides of
the equation by x
we will get x to the power of seven is
equal to x squared
from here we are going to modify each of
these fractions let's make each
numerator in the fraction x to the power
of 5.
the first fraction will multiply by x to
the power 4 over x to the power 4. the
second fraction will multiply by x to
the power of 3 over x to the power of 3.
the next fraction will multiply by x
squared over x squared and the last
fraction we'll multiply by x over x
we'll simplify each of these fractions
the first fraction will become x to the
power of 5 divided by x to the power of
4 plus x to the power 6.
the second fraction will be x to the
power 5 divided by x to the power of 3
plus x to the power of 7.
the next fraction will be x to the power
5 divided by x squared plus x cubed and
the last fraction will be x to the power
5 divided by x plus x to the power of 4.
from here we'll simplify each fraction
recall that x to the power 5 is equal to
1. so all of the numerators will become
1. then x to the power of 6 is equal to
x which we'll substitute into the first
fraction
from here x to the power of 7 is equal
to x squared so we'll substitute that
into the second fraction
from here the second and third fractions
have exactly the same denominator
so their sum will be 2 divided by x
squared plus x cubed
then the first and last fractions also
have the same denominator so their sum
will be 2 divided by x plus x to the
power 4.
we now want to add these two fractions
to do that we'll get a common
denominator
so from the first fraction we'll
multiply by x plus x to the power 4
divided by x plus x to the power 4. in
the second fraction we'll multiply by x
squared plus x cubed divided by x
squared plus x cubed
the first fraction simplifies to be the
following the second fraction simplifies
to be the following
we then want to sum these two fractions
since they have the same denominator we
can simply sum their numerators
so we get the following fraction
we can then simplify this because we'll
recall that x to the power of 6 is equal
to x and x to the power of 7 is equal to
x squared
so the denominator becomes the following
and then we'll simply rearrange it in
ascending order
so we finally have this fraction where
we have 2 multiplied by x plus x squared
plus x cubed plus x to the fourth and
the denominator is exactly that same
quantity x plus x squared plus x cubed
plus x to the power 4.
so these two quantities will cancel
and thus this all simplifies to be
exactly equal to 2.
the answer is too good
thanks for making us one of the best
channels on youtube see you next episode
of mind your decisions where we solve
the world's problems one video at a time
[Music]
you